President Trump says Democratic senator
dick durbin is hurting chances of
reaching an immigration deal Durbin says
that the President did use a vulgar word
to describe some immigrants during an
oval office meeting last week mr. Trump
tweeted last night quote senator Dickie
Durban totally misrepresented what was
said at the daka meeting deals can't get
made when there is no trust
Democrats want the daca program
protecting young illegal immigrants to
be part of a deal to avoid a government
shutdown by Friday major Garrett is at
the White House with the latest on this
story major good morning good morning
here's a big question for President
Trump this year can he cut deals with
Democrats last year all the biggest
deals while only with Republicans and
bipartisanship 2018 is in trouble after
a promising start members just a week
ago Cabinet Room president Trump bunch
of lawmakers nearly an hour of televised
immigration give-and-take where the
president said he would sign anything
because he could quote take the heat
well then came the backlash hardliners
accused mr. Trump of weakness and toying
with amnesty by providing protection
from deportation for immigrants brought
to the country illegally by their
parents and at the prodding of chief of
staff John Kelly and domestic policy
adviser Stephen Miller the president
demanded more money for a border wall an
end to visa the visa lottery system and
reduced immigration through family ties
well that complicated Oval Office talks
late last week tempers flared the
president used a vulgarity and that
expletive and its racial overtones have
stalled immigration talks a government
shutdown looms and now the debt
president is trying to blame Democrats
and Democrats alone for this impasse
welcome John to this mid-january summary
of bipartisanship president Trump style
major thank you for that